let's get to wimbledon gate because
there's a big scandal brewing as we run
towards the wimbledon championships
because there will be no ranking points
now to play for after the wimbledon
organizers decided to ban russian and
belarusian athletes well frenchman lucas
poole became the first top player to
declare he won't play in the world's
most prestigious tennis tournament uh
naomi osaka has probably come forward
and said she may not either saying it
would be pointless i'm sure someone else
would probably take your place but it's
clearly a tournament now in turmoil
it's kind of like
i don't want to say pointless
no pun intended but like
like i
i i'm the type of player that gets
motivated by like seeing
my ranking go up or like you know stuff
like that i think the intention was
really good but the execution is kind of
all over the place
joining me to discuss all this is 18
times grand slam tennis champion martina
and that rattle over martina thank you
for joining me we did discuss this a few
weeks ago didn't we and things have
really escalated now where it's becoming
this massive furore uh i gotta say since
we last spoke i think i shared your view
then that punishing individuals uh
seemed the wrong way to punish putin um
but i then interviewed vladimir
klitschko the the ukrainian boxer last
week and he said this to me
the war is going on
they cannot participate in the next
olympic games they cannot participate at
any
athletic events
because
this war
is represented by russia
so atlas representing russia and there
is definitely connection
i'm going to say that when i listened to
him speaking so powerfully he did
slightly sway me i've got to be honest
because i i can just imagine a situation
where a russian tennis star
ends up winning a wimbledon trophy and
you know has it presented to him or her
by the duchess of cambridge for example
what a pr bonanza that would be for
vladimir putin right now and something
that we i just don't think as a country
could tolerate that kind of scenario
unfurling so i'm not sure that wimbledon
have had a lot of choice given the
pressure from the uk government to do
this
sure i i understand so much where uh the
players uh and and people in the ukraine
are coming from a hundred percent i can
still relate to this
um i am thinking there's a big
difference between team events and any
individual events
and also you have russian and belarusian
players on team sports for example
alexey ovichkin playing for the
washington capitals in the nhl not a
peep out of anybody that he should not
be playing
for for for that team plus he's a
massive supporter of vladimir putin on
top of that so you have a player like
rublev who has
disowned the war he had written on the
camera no to war yet he can't play
um so it's just
you look there's no winning situation
here and now you have a controversial
decision if it was the right thing i
think we would not be so ambivalent
about it um
both ways um
so it's
it's just no good way out of it bad
situation of course horrible situation
with the war bad situation with the with
with one button making this rule and now
another kind of iffy decision and not
not giving the points but you just try
to make the best out of a horrible
situation you were still playing
if you were still playing martina at the
top of your game and may even be in the
running as you were of course many times
to win a wimbledon title uh what would
you have done if the points weren't
there to be won
would you have taken a view like naomi
osaka and said well actually in that
case i'm not going to play would you
taken a principled stand in support of
russian and belarusian tennis players
what would your view of being do you
think
no i would well first of all i wouldn't
i could care less that there were no
points uh given because i always play
for the trophies not the points and not
the money
so uh for me it was wimbledon and
nothing else and and everything else
came in second so the points were
this is not an exhibition uh i i don't
understand that view that players
wouldn't play because there are no
points so you're playing for computer
ranking
uh i just wanted to hold that uh hold
the trophy uh that wonderful
the wonderful venus rose dish so um
it's you know there's no good way out of
this but i don't understand the players
that say they don't want to play because
of points uh this is why you play tennis
right to get points onto the computer
and see your ranking going up or down or
whatever i could have cared less when i
won one but i didn't know that i became
number one they i don't learn that in
the press conference when they told me
by the way you're number one i'm like oh
great that's just cherry on the cake
it's i mean maybe osaka i've got to say
barely a week goes by without naomi
osaka whining about something is she
just got all her priorities wrong should
she go back to just wanting to win big
trophies and keep quiet i
well it's kind of nice if you can walk
away from a potential what two million
pound uh
you know payday
uh most people don't have that luxury uh
but uh i i just don't understand that
mentality and and uh i would like to sit
down with her and just tell her about
the history of one buddha oh and you
know the russian players volusion
players
occur to her that she would not play
right if they were playing points
weren't taken away so
uh i i don't understand that mentality
but i you know there's a lot of things
that i don't understand these days
[Laughter]
well i think if they all had your
winning mentality trust me they win a
lot more tournaments because you were
one of the all-time greats martina let
me ask you just about another ongoing
raging issue that you've been vocal
about you've been attacked over
i want to know what your feelings are
about it now but this whole issue of
trans athletes in women's sport is not
going away if anything it's it's it's
gathering momentum and ferocity you know
when you try and discuss it in public as
you found as i've found others have
found however fair and tolerant you try
and be in the way you talk about it
there is just fury that erupts um
where are we with this debate and where
should we be trying to get to
well this insistence on not just being
accepted but uh but but allowed to
compete uh in in in sports when clearly
we have categories in sports for a
reason by weight by sex uh and and uh
when it comes to sports it's about
biology not about identity and uh the
aclu the
american civil liberties union in in
america has gone as far as saying that
trans women should be accepted into
women's force with no mitigation
whatsoever we don't care about
testosterone nothing else it's all about
how you feel and you have to be
accepting and and and welcoming and
clearly that would be the end of women's
force because there are enough trans
trans women now where they would take
over women's sports if there is no
mitigation and what we have really found
i have done a lot of studying on this is
that once um men had boys hit puberty
become men it's impossible to mitigate
that advantage that is automatic given
uh for for for male bodies uh biological
males is it as damaging i mean people
have called it trans people let me just
say i accept trans people for who they
are yeah in normal society but when it
comes to sports it's about biology and
we have to draw the line there there's
no other way around it to me it's not as
willful as other forms of cheating but
it has the same effect you know i don't
blame the trans athletes if they're
allowed to do this it's legal as things
stand but it has the same effect as
doping and other forms of cheating
doesn't it
well testosterone you know there's a
reason why we why we limit testosterone
for women athletes we're not allowed to
take testosterone to get stronger that's
what you had in the 70s and 80s when the
east germans and soviets frankly were
taking testosterone up to wazoo and uh
and winning women biological women had
no chance against doped up women like
that and
trans women have a lot more testosterone
naturally uh even if they start taking
those drugs and and and lower lower the
levels the effects are still there the
the muscle mass the lung capacity of
course the skeletons and change all of
that is just not possible to mitigate
that advantage you know what it's just
the bottom line it's just not fair and
i've followed you about this you've been
so rational and calm and fair-minded
about it but it's not going away it's
got to be dealt with the women's sport
will just get destroyed martina
brilliant to talk to you thank you very
much
thanks a lot